Oh my god Mark,
I have the best idea for an app!
It's going to totally change the world.
>> Oh, yeah?
>> Yeah, it will totally revolutionize
how left handed people meet each other.
>> Really?
>> It's so simple Mark.
You'll be shown pictures
of other lefties near you,
and you'll swipe them to the right if
you don't think they're interesting, and
you'll swipe them to the left If
they're a lefty you would like to meet.
>> Brilliant, I'm sure.
>> Ugh, you wouldn't understand.
Look at you,
standing there in your righty privilege.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Well I just wanted to thank you for
teaching me everything there
is to know about Gradle.
I'm going to be using the Gradle Java
plugin to build my Android app.
I just thought you'd be proud.
>> Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
We barely scratched
the surface of Gradle.
There's a lot more to building
an Android app than just compiling some
Java code.
>> No,
I'm pretty sure I know everything.
I'm changing the world, remember?
>> I know, I know.
But, let's take a look at how
the Android build process works, first.
>> I promise we'll change
the world tomorrow.
>> Fine.